always it on okay okay why don't we go
ahead and get started I can barely see
people up there there are seats down
here if you want to be closer but that's
okay anyways I want to welcome everyone
to summer session as you know we don't
have the research conference all summer
just intermittently when there's a
reason to have it and there is a reason
to have it this time because we have a
special guest from University of
Victoria who is a world-known expert in
patient safety and health IT which is a
big issue and she's going to be spending
some additional time here over the next
few months I believe okay so Elizabeth
bricky is an associate professor in the
is it the school of health information
science at the University of Victoria
our colleagues just up the road a bit
sexy a shame that we don't well maybe
this will facilitate more interaction
there's actually discussion of forming
an a mia chapter in the Pacific
Northwest kind of like they've done in
the mid-atlantic region so between
Victoria and Seattle and here anyways um
she brings a background in both Nursing
and Health Policy she has her PhD from
the University of Toronto and she is
going to be talking to us today on a
chai tea safety
hi everyone can you hear me okay yes I
apologize that I am a bit rusty I'm
lecturing so it always takes me a little
while to get loud enough so let me know
if I'm not loud for people at the back
so today what I'm going to talk about is
health information technology safety
issues and solutions so I'm going to
talk a little bit about some of the
research that has been going on at the
University of Victoria some the research
that that I've got other letter been
involved with as well as sort of mixed
it in with some of the things that are
going on actually here it's one of the
reasons why I've come here is because
Hsu has done some really excellent will
work in and around the safety area so
I'll start off with a little background
in history in the 1990s we saw a lot
studies that were published highlighting
the number of medical errors that could
occur during the provision of care
what's really interesting is as a result
of that work we had a lot of health
information systems that were identified
as possible solutions for addressing
these types of medical errors so systems
such as physician order entry systems
decision support systems pharmacy
systems as well as clinical
documentation so we had in North America
is that policy recommendations came out
to actually suggest this idea that we
implement health information systems in
order to reduce the likelihood of having
medical errors occur and this is a
phenomenon that occurred in in North
America as well as Europe and in other
parts of the world now what's
interesting is in 2004 we started to see
research emerge suggesting that
technology could lead to medical errors
and this tech this research suggested
that the stat technologies could not
only reduce medical errors but they
could introduce new types of errors when
introduced into clinical settings so the
main finding of this research was that
errors have their origins and health
information systems so health
informatics research documented the
emergence of these types of errors and
I'm going to refer to them as technology
induced errors because that's one of the
terms that's used but you can actually
see other terms being used to refer to
these types of errors they're also
referred to and in some
unintended consequences yet Roe Genesis
technology facilitated errors and also
health information system problems so
there's different terms that are used
for this particular type of error in
terms of technology induced errors we
should talk about a little bit about the
definition so sort of give you an idea
of what what we've been doing in terms
of our research here at the University
Victoria we define technology induced
errors as those sources of error that
arise from the design and development of
a technology its implementation and
customization as well as the
interactions between the operation of
the new technology and the newer work
processes that arise from technologies
used and this includes there is that
such as actual mistakes so you have an
actual error that takes place involving
the technology and slip so near misses
that occur so a health professional is
working with the technology identifies
an error has occurred and then actually
corrects that error to give you a little
bit of an example of a typical type of
issue a few years ago we did some
simulation work actually this work was
done in Japan where we looked at the use
of a medication administration system by
by both nurses and physicians now this
is actually a just a screenshot so this
was a simulation there's an obvious ly a
dummy patient here so let's see so
that's the mannequin down there this is
an artificial case and where we have a
health professional is actually
interacting with the system and also
providing care to the artificial patient
while using a system itself and it was
an interesting study because what it did
is did identified a number of issues
which I'm going to talk a little bit
more about but what we did it what we
did was a essentially an experimental
study where we we actually recorded what
they were doing we actually took a look
at and transcribed what they were
actually saying while they're performing
the tasks and then what we did is a
semi-structured interviewed afterwards
it's a form of cued recall where we ask
the person what was happening during the
actual situation you know this also
involves looking at video in some cases
and actually cueing the person and
asking what was going on at that point
of time it was really interesting so you
could start to see how technology starts
to influence practice so in this
particular case for example the scanner
actually didn't respond
in all cases the cord on the scanner was
too short to reach the patient so these
were all potential sources of Technology
induced errors and this was particularly
considered a problem and processed in
terms of health professionals who are
using the technology thinking that
perhaps it would take too much time to
actually engage in the entire sequence
of events in order to get a medication
when a patient needed urgent help so
some other findings that we had included
things such as there were fundamental
changes to the workflow for the
particular task it changed from parallel
to serial what's kind of interesting
about that in actually doing medications
or administering medications multiple
medications more complex ones we saw the
cognitive load actually increase for
this particular group of individuals so
you started to think about the
interactions between actually what
happens in real clinical practice and
what actually happens in terms of how
the technology is designed so it might
have been designed more so for someone
administering one or two medications
rather than ten medications and some of
those indication medications may include
things such as oral meds they may
include an injection and they also may
include hanging IV medications so what
it started to do is start to look at
thinking too kind of the kinds of issues
that might actually potentially
introduce potential errors into the
system because when you have the
situation occur and a health
professional really wants to get an
outcome I want to make sure that my
patient gets their medications so they
can so they can improve their health you
start to see health professionals trying
to in essence to work around the system
and these workarounds sometimes lead to
errors and the workarounds a result of
poor technology design and oftentimes
poor technology implementation other
examples that we've seen of technology
induced errors in the literature include
things such as fragmenting of patient
information a study that I did I looked
at how nurses perform in pure paper
versus hybrid environments it was really
quite interesting the number of data
points that the nurses attended to in
the paper environment were much higher
than the number of data points that they
attended to in the hybrid environment
interestingly enough when they were
asked you know so what was happening in
the hybrid environment that that led you
to to behave in the way that you did the
nurses identified that it was very
confusing to be able to move between the
hybrid and the electronic paper
electronic record and as a result they
cut out from their decision making their
their actual formation of their mental
model a lot earlier so their mental
model was robust in the paper
environment but not so much so in the
electronic environment because of this
confusion and moving back and forth
other things that have introduced errors
technology knust errors include layout
and organization of information also
there's been some research that has
shown that people can become screen
driven as a result of the way that the
system presents the information and that
can actually lead to suboptimal clinical
practice in addition to that they're
specific features and functions of user
interfaces it actually may be associated
more so with technology induced errors
such as for example defaults you have a
default that popular auto populates a
particular field the health professional
thinks that they've entered the correct
information but in essence what's
happened is the default is popped in a
different value and then they submit the
order okay another example other things
that have happened in terms of
technology induced errors include things
such as documenting on the wrong patient
record and that can sometimes happen
because the color of the font on the
different records or you might not
realize you actually have more than one
patient record open at the same time one
of the issues also that it's kind of
coming up in the last couple of years is
this whole notion of visibility of
information in the record as you lose
smaller and smaller devices to view
patient information it becomes more
difficult to actually see what's is
there in addition to that you can have
records that have poor navigation they
can be inconsistent a good example of
that is the date month and year may be
inconsistent between different modules
within the record leading someone to
make the mistake about when the last
medication was given terminology
differences exist between records and
even within records and you can also see
that work arounds are a significant part
of trying to actually work with these
records and they and them of themselves
represent an opportunity to have a
technology induced error because the
workaround arises from the technologies
poor interface designer / workflows so
where does technology to induce terrors
come from they come from requirements
specification design development
programming customization implementation
as well as maintenance of the system
what's kind of interesting about that is
if you look at technology within the
context of healthcare healthcare work
and of itself makes technology or pushes
technology to the point where we have to
create systems that are extremely robust
enable in order for that technology to
respond effectively efficiently and to
support health professional work health
professional work is time limit its
variable is uncertain it's highly
complex there's high degrees of urgency
at different points in time it's also
heavily regulated by in our case federal
and provincial levels of government so
it's very very complex and I know in our
area and in Canada oftentimes that is
healthcare is often compared to aviation
or banking or even nuclear power and I
would suggest that we are even more
complex that even those areas in terms
of the types of technologies that need
to be developed in order to support work
so it's the uniqueness or the context of
healthcare that actually makes
technology have to be able to be more
responsive more fluid more better
developed in such a way that it will
actually support health professional
work this is a model of technology
induced error that I worked on a couple
of years ago now it's interesting about
it is you can have errors introduced at
different points in time so for example
this is the individual so this is what I
call the health care professional who's
working with the technology and there's
a lot of insertion points in terms of
where an error can actually be
introduced so for example let's say
you're working with your health
information system and the government
changes some fundamental regulation on a
particular day the health information
system doesn't necessarily support that
particular regulation then the health
professional uses a system and makes an
error is it the health professionals
fault you might have errors introduced
in other parts for example you might
have a vendor system that builds their
technology based on a model healthcare
organization oops what happens if that
particular model healthcare organization
has errors in it errors in processes
errors become embedded in the technology
in the process of programming you take
that particular vendor system and you
move it into an
their organization then that
organization takes on those errors also
you may also introduce errors from the
perspective that that model organization
may model a different type of health
care system so for example there may be
one approach to providing care so let's
say Canada in the United States both
have different types of healthcare
systems there are similarities and there
are some differences and sometimes those
differences emerge actually in the
software and you start having to make
modifications to softer to replicate
processes or those differences in the
healthcare in healthcare system there's
a vendor organization you can have
issues with how the vendor did
requirements gathering design the system
programmed at how they did their
software testing you can also have
issues introduced or technology induced
errors introduced at the local
healthcare organizational level so for
example in addition to the software
itself the local organization may have
different devices they made have
different workflows from the model
organization their interface design they
may want to change it you might have
different use of local terminologies
which versus what is actually in the
vendor system different policies and
procedures versus what was originally
supported in that vendor system and as
well as local testing may actually entry
it's not done adequately man may
actually not catch certain types of
technology and do stairs and then last
but not least you have the individual
using the system incorrectly in some
cases but they may be using it correctly
and all these things may lead to an
error occurring at this particular point
of time so I have a background in the
quality improvement literature and if
you look at the quality improvement
literature it's really quite interesting
ninety percent of errors or systems
related and ten percent are human errors
and it starts to become important we
start looking at that individual is
actually using a particular information
system and you think about all the
different insertion points where you
could actually have something change
that would lead to an error some form of
error that would occur down here so I'm
an advocate of very much so taking a
systems approach when you start to look
at technology induced errors because
something might happen down here we need
to track back to find out where the root
cause or source of those particular
errors is what's interesting about
technology and do stairs is we're
just beginning to start to document
these types of areas although there has
been some documentation of it we are
still introducing new technologies we're
still interfacing electronic health
record circuits right with different
types of medical devices and we're
introducing new types of consumer
technologies that have healthcare
applications so we still don't know what
all the different types of errors are so
every time a software is introduced
hardware is introduced santa systems are
integrated or you make any modifications
there's always an opportunity for some
type of technology induced error occur
so I have the hypothesis that this is an
area of research that will be ongoing
for many many years the main reason is
is as technology changes new errors will
be introduced and we need to be able to
identify when and where they're
occurring and prevent them from
occurring in the real world setting so
part of that is understanding how those
that technology works and how it works
in a complex health healthcare system as
well as the situational context and
patient context where those errors can
emerge so why is it important we need to
develop prevention strategies and
identify solutions we need to identify
models as well as the underlying reasons
for why these particular technologies
induced errors occur with this idea that
we need to have best practices in how we
actually implement systems how we design
develop how we gather requirements for
developing these types of systems the
beginning of that is understanding how
these errors occur and there's a number
of different types of models that have
actually come out and it's interesting
there's models that have their origins
in human factors the organizational
behavior and social technical
literature's as well as software
engineering and there is overlap between
the models when you start to look at
them what's interesting is the human
factors models actually look at the
humor computer interaction literature as
well as the cognitive science literature
and there's quite a few that have been
developed for this area so for example
Jang developed a cognitive taxonomy of
classifying errors blumer Osen also
developed an input-output model for
looking at unintended consequences where
errors are concerned in addition to that
we've other had other organizational
behavior theories and social technical
theories that have inform these models
social technical theory has been
extremely important and in fact
actually mentioned in the institute of
medicine report in and around health
information system safety and also with
rogers innovation diffusion theory also
looking at how technology is
disseminated and what aspects are
attribute so that technology may
influence its dissemination and this
actually has importance because you know
a technology that's not disseminating
well may have errors associated with it
fantastically health professionals are
trying to figure out a way of saying
well you know maybe this isn't working
for me or if working for the clinical
setting so you have to consider these
types of things when looking at
technology you're looking at how you
actually design develop and implement
and then maintain it last but not least
there's software engineering models now
these are important from the perspective
that these are the technology designers
models in terms of looking at the
technology how they would go about
designing and testing it and making sure
that it is available for use in a
clinical setting part of these these
models are important from the
perspective that they can also be used
to test for safety so what do we need is
we need a number of different types of
methods to actually diagnose technology
induced errors and that they need to be
unique to the healthcare setting what's
kind of interesting is if you look back
to 2004 and and the work that's been
going on in the last couple of years
both qualitative and quantitative
approaches have been significant from
the perspective that they have shed
different lenses on this particular type
of problem I always like to think of
quantitative approaches as counting the
number of errors that occur out there
and qualitative approaches actually
describing them ideally I think we need
to have mixed method approaches where
we're actually identifying and
describing errors as well as counting
how many L often they occur now in terms
of the continuum for looking at at
technology and do stairs or diagnosing
technology and do stairs you can look at
them in terms of different methods and
approaches that can be used before
systems implemented during its
implementation as well as after an error
has occurred so we're going to talk a
little bit about that it's kind of
interesting what we did in Canada is we
actually identified a particular
methodology that could be
use to look at before systems are
implemented so I'm going to talk a
little bit about evidence-based safety
heuristics clinical simulations as well
as computer-based simulations as part of
our work early on what we did is we
looked at some of the research in and
around when errors actually occur in the
types of errors that occur and you could
actually bubble that down into four
different areas you can have technology
and do stairs arise from content issues
workflow issues and functional issues as
well as the lack or absence of different
types of safeguards so for example the
decision support system that will warn
someone that there isn't particular
issue and we looked at that literature
and actually developed this based on a
review of different types of articles as
well as discussions and amongst several
different experts and here is an example
of some of the heuristics that we use
now what we've done since then is we've
actually applied this to differing types
of health information systems and
successfully been able to identify
potential issues with a system before
it's been implemented and this type of
work can be done by the analyst so an
analyst that's looking at a system or
multiple different systems that the
hospital may decide to actually purchase
and you can identify potential safety
problems before the purchase actually
takes place so the other thing that
we've used is clinical simulations what
we recognized and using heuristic
evaluation is that has limitations it
doesn't actually capture the dynamic
elements of a particular health
information system and how it functions
within the context of a real-world
clinical environment so what we did is
we worked on this idea that you have a
clinical simulation and it would be a
methodology for identify potentially
potential technology induced errors
before an implementation occurs so what
does that involve in a while observing
health professionals interacting with
systems using representative devices in
typical workplace is carrying out
representative tasks and representative
tasks can be varied from the routine to
the complex the typical to the atypical
and the non non urgent to the urgent now
this is really important to consider
from the perspective that moths most
health information systems are developed
for more routine tasks typical
activities and non urgent activity
so this idea that you have this range in
these different areas it's very
important from the perspective that you
essentially you want to be able to throw
a wrench at that system and say let's
see how far we can push it and how well
it supports work in unusual situations
because we know as healthcare
professionals we always encounter the
unusual situation and we need to have
systems that can support that this work
actually was extended there is a group
actually in Denmark who have a
simulation lab what they've done is
they've taken the clinical simulations
and added them added the technology
component to it and use this particular
approach to actually identify systems
that would be candidate systems for
implementing in their particular
Regional Health Authority in fact
they're using this approach to identify
systems that would be suitable for
purchase as a part of a procurement
process so important things to remember
with clinical simulations you need to
make sure the environment is similar to
what you would typically be working with
the tasks are similar the users that of
the system would be similar as well as
scenarios so you have this notion of
ecological validity so you can have
representative findings so if you're
actually going about procuring or
purchasing a system that you actually
create you actually put that system
through the same pressures that it would
normally experience in your particular
clinical setting again with this idea
that you're testing it out before you
actually implement and and have
downstream effects so again clinical
simulations a great way of actually
doing this type of work the video
recordings are extremely informative the
computer screen recordings give you an
idea how the software performs in terms
of interface design and workflow in the
other piece to and most importantly is
you get health professional feedback on
different types of situations we've had
successes in terms of this technology
this particular methodology in terms of
convincing people to make modifications
to health information systems changes to
the types of devices that are used in
conjunction with electronic health
records changing policies and
organizations as well as developing
different types of training approaches
so an extension that this particular
methodology also includes computer based
simulation
so in this particular case we have
clinical simulations that take place and
what we do is we use that as inputs into
computer-based simulations so you can
actually make projections about the
effects of a particular technology
induced error over time the importance
of this is that what you can do is you
can actually show decision-makers what
the implications are of making changes
to the software or to the workflow
that's embedded in the software through
changes to the actual interface and then
they can see what the implications are
imagine an error that is an important
one that is commonly that commonly
occurs with your particular system
projected out over a period of weeks
months and years and you know this is
all in an artificial environment which
is in essence a nice way of finding out
what the potential problems would be and
do you really want to have those
particular problems it becomes a very
convincing argument when you work with
chief information officers and chief
medical information officers about
deciding about what types of what
aspects of the user interface design
might actually be changed and it's a
nice way of actually managing risk
because what you can do is you can start
looking at at errors that were created
in a clinical simulation environment and
you look at which particular errors you
can add develop policies and procedures
for as which ones you can develop
training for and which ones you actually
can actually spend the spend the cost
and the money to to change that
particular user interface of course
there's ethnography and I'm going to
mention this because I think this is a
very important methodology and and I
think there's been a lot of excellent
work that's been done here as far as
clinical simulations and ethnography at
ohsu now ethnography is really really
important from the perspective that you
can catch a lot of areas using this
particular methodology and what's
beautiful about this particular
methodologies it shows that healthcare
professionals can actually identify
instances where health information
systems errors are occurring and that
they see these things occurring in real
world settings and are able to report on
these particular types of errors really
important from the perspective that it
gives an excellent argument for why we
need to construct monitoring systems and
reporting systems for health
professionals so we can start looking at
collecting this type of data so we can
provide this type of in for me
to health information systems vendors
and of course the other thing too is in
this particular Oregon Health Sciences
University you've also pioneered rapid
assessment approaches which allow you to
actually collect this kind of data in
the first little while after an
implementation extremely important from
the perspective because people are
starting to learn how to use the health
information system and you can
particularly identify those types of
issues that can be addressed from a
training perspective and and let people
know how to effectively use the system
so you can prevent errors from occurring
last but not least there's also
methodologies that have been developed
after a particular error has occurred
and these are important also they allow
us to actually look back at that
particular model and say where were the
sources of those though they are where
can we in essence close some holes in
order to prevent that individual that
clinician from making an error and a
good example of that is some of the work
that was done by Jana horse key where he
looked at the root causes and potential
causes of errors involving failures of
interaction and it's kind of interesting
because when you look at the methodology
that horse key uses what he does is he
scopes out that need for actually having
a broader view in terms of the types of
data that you would have to look at in
the types of experts that we need to be
involved you no longer have a team of
individuals who are perhaps clinicians
looking at how an error occurred you
need to start including health
informatics experts you need to start
including people who understand human
factors and software and hardware and
how things are put together in order to
be able to address these types of errors
so I'm also going to talk a little bit
about usability usability from the
perspective that it can actually be a
methodology for identifying potential
errors both before during and after
implementation now what is usability
it's essentially the measure of ease of
use of a system and learning in terms of
learning effectiveness efficiency
enjoyability and last but not least
safety it's kind of interesting that
this has sort of been much done in the
last couple years from the perspective
that it occurred in other literature's
but less so in health care so what is
usability it's an individual who is
using a system we
ask them to think aloud while they're
using a system and in response to a
particular type of case usability
involves different methods so we have
inspection methods which I've talked a
little bit about we have usability
testing methods that you can use where
you can actually look at the occurrence
of particular usability issues in
relation to differing types of
technology induced areas that are
present out there so there's direct
collect correct correlations and
connections between specific types of
usability problems whether or not an
individual actually makes a mistake and
then what you do is you can look at
usability in the context of clinical
simulations where you start to
understand with specific aspects of the
user interface design and the workflows
actually lead to errors occurring from a
technology perspective so if you look at
models you can start thinking a little
bit more broadly here where you start to
look at how do you make a system safer
you can start thinking of it in terms of
phases so when would you do this you
would perhaps start looking at the
safety of a system before youth but
while you're actually developing or
designing it with prototypes you could
do heuristic evaluation on that correct
defects you could do testing in and
around it you could do clinical
simulations you could again correct
correct defects in and along the way you
might even go as far as to do
naturalistic testing so in situ testing
ethnographic observation and you might
be able to actually identify errors that
occur down here now this is this idea
that what you're doing between here and
here is your pruning off the number of
areas that are experienced the earlier
to take care of this problem the less
costly it is so down here you could
actually take care of it while you still
have a prototype so you're not spending
the money on developing a full-blown
system the vendors can be involved in
this type of process and as you get
closer and closer to where it's
implementing that particular system what
you're doing is you're adding on these
different layers of testing so by the
time that you're done you have a fairly
safe system okay it's gone through
multiple different layers
and there's no difference between this
particular type of approach in terms of
looking at layers and doing testing at
different points in time and what you
have for hat for example in the aviation
industry it's seldom that we have Boeing
for example probably wouldn't develop a
prototype and expect passengers to fly
at the next day fly in it the next day
instead what they're doing is they're
actually going through this process this
layering to identify potential issues so
that they can produce the best aircraft
possible so the day that it's launched
it actually is very effective and very
safe as we can see so I'm getting closer
to the end of my presentation I think
technology induced errors are very very
important I think we're just at the tip
of the iceberg of these types of errors
interestingly enough I think there's a
lot more down here and probably this
will either grow or shrink depending on
how much we identify in terms of best
practices and best practices are key
here because we can probably shrink this
if we have more individuals doing
testing and identifying what kinds of
issues are could potentially happen and
correcting for those things before a
system is actually implemented and used
I think today what we're in is a
situation where you have self some so
it's health information systems that are
safe and some that are unsafe and there
is an it's a continuum so you might have
different system features or functions
that are in here that are safe and
unsafe and this is the beautiful part of
it is we need to find out what's good in
here so we can move to more it's safer
systems okay and this is a process and
it takes time but means we need to start
doing this more effectively and we need
to have more research in this particular
area and one of the reasons why I'm here
is because research in this area it has
occurred here and is moving this this
particular continuum forward I'm also
very pleased in saying that some of the
research has happened here as well as in
Canada and other parts of the world led
to the Institute of Medicine really
looking at technology and do stairs and
going from a point where they said you
know we have to go down the route of
implementing health information systems
to now highlighting this idea that we
need to build safer systems
and that this is a concern and it
happened in a very short period of time
2004 to 2011 that's I think that's a
very short time period considering the
amount of time it takes to disseminate
knowledge in the next couple years I
think what's going to be interesting is
we're going to have to look at things
such as the infrastructures that are
used to actually look at health
information system safety we need to
identify what a reporting and monitoring
what reporting and monitoring systems
are needed out there given the fact that
these errors have not been fully or not
all the errors have been described some
have and that more errors and different
types of errors will emerge in the next
couple years as we introduce new
software and new technology new hardware
devices and we interface them we also
need to have these types of methods
where we start to test to see what types
of safety issues may emerge with that
particular type of system and in
addition to that we need to start
thinking about how we provide feedback
into how we can improve these types of
systems through these types of tests
before these systems are implemented
before clinicians use them an idealized
world would be as we would have
technology induced errors occur in a
minimum and that we would have
clinicians feel that they're comfortable
with their information systems and that
they're safe to use and not have to
worry about you know did I did I did
that default pop up at the last minute
they should be thinking about whether or
not you know that whether there should
be comfortable with knowing that I've
ordered the right medications and the
default has been it was correct and all
of this actually factors in in terms of
best practices so little baby steps to
create in essence best practices and
around how to deal with technology
induced errors across this entire
continuum and and so I'm actually really
happy to be here from the perspective
that there's been people here who have
worked on safer guides which to me is
very important because it's bringing
this idea forward we need to start doing
safe best practices and there are
resources that need to be out there for
all of us in the industry to use from
the vendor through to the educator
through to the implementer
hospital through to the consumer who's
out there who is sitting there looking
at their system going I don't know if
that worked correctly is it giving me
the right information so these are the
kinds of things that we need to consider
from that perspective this is my contact
information if anybody wants to contact
me afterwards and that's the end of my
presentation the question I have is how
generalizable are the results from your
analysis thinking in terms of if errors
with health IT are related to sort of
systems and their local implementation
and people and the things they do
locally if there's so much variation we
hear this about health IT you know that
it's not a one-size-fits-all but if
we're going to make a headway against
errors with systems that we want people
to use how we're going to do that I
don't imagine every small community
hospital can be doing usability studies
and bringing usability engineers and and
so forth we select that Mexican a
clinical implementation in there but how
do you see this scaling out to address
the very real problem well I think
what's interesting in and looking at the
research and doing some of the research
myself is there certain types of errors
that are consistently occurring and then
they're not necessarily specific to a
vendor so a good example of that is a
default auto populates a field and the
clinician mrs. that and that's not the
clinicians fault that something to do
with the actual system itself so you
could actually in essence turn off the
default for that particular field now
knowing these types of things you could
actually develop guides for vendors
where they actually start to see that
there are certain things you do in a
health care environment and other things
that you may not do unfortunately I
think we are just beginning to sort of
scratch the surface of this
we need to start having guides where
we're detailing out this information and
these these guys over time will need to
be updated depending on what type of
researchers out there in terms of
usability testing my colleague Vanya
Kirk has actually developed the low cost
approach and it's kind of interesting
you can actually do your usability
testing in your local regional health
authority and in fact it's quite
commonplace for people who are either
taking graduate studies or undergraduate
studies in our program to actually
conduct usability tests with
technologies what's kind of interesting
about that is this they've been
effective and actually making changes to
the technologies as well as providing
feedback to the vendors so I've done my
usability test identified that there are
certain usability issues associated with
technology and do stairs I provide that
to the vendor as information in terms of
their releases and I also have that
information to make changes to the
product locally so and again it
addresses this whole notion that perhaps
you know you might have some differences
between organisations but increasingly I
mean if you look at technology itself
there's certain aspects certain
technology induced errors that keep
recurring so we can develop some
standards and around which shouldn't
shouldn't be used we can also do
localized testing to address what
happens when you implement something and
identify what potential issues there
I'll make modifications or
customizations at that point as well as
provide feedback to the vendor because I
don't think these cases are unique i
think the vendors need to hear the same
story over and over again to make
modifications over time I hope I
answered your question yes
hoarsely
so the question was is did I see
anything in around technology induced
errors in the fact that systems were
developed initially for reimbursement
purposes no no I have I mean in my
research we we haven't actually looked
at it from that approach and from what
I've got it from what I've looked at in
terms of articles there isn't that that
specific focus on that particular issue
I think what you're what you're seeing
more so is how do you these technology
induce errors how do they emerge when
when a person is dealing with urgent
clinical event and I guess you know this
is a value judgment about amount health
information systems right should they be
used to support patient care or just to
collect information from a billing
perspective and can we find something
that sort of rest in between where its
services both worlds right you can still
collect your information but at the same
time you have something that will be
very safe because ultimately ultimately
if you have an error occurred technology
induced error and it leads to harm to a
patient there's costs associated with
treating that patient after the fact
right and in the costs are high so I
mean it makes sense to make a safe
system right
I mean you in theory you could wipe out
any savings you had using the
information system if you if you had
enough errors occur right I'm going to
go to the fellow with the blue shirt cuz
I yes well it's so the question is is
how can you how can field researchers
and field research contribute to the
development of ecologically valid
simulations I think it's it's
interesting that you mention it because
you can actually use that research as a
way of informing how those particular
simulations are developed in fact what
you can do is you can identify cases
where you feel that errors are occurring
and for example someone's correcting you
know you have a health professional is
working away and they oh there's a
mistake I have to fix it but you want
you could actually look at that and say
okay how can we replicate that in a
clinical setting in a clinical
simulation context and you could
redesign that particular user interface
and see if it went away and if it does
go away then you can provide a rational
argument as to why you might need to
change that user interface so it makes
total sense and it's a way of improving
the actual implementation as well as you
can provide feedback to the vendor right
because the system is there yes any
other questions I'm going to go down
here and then up so yes
you know the question isn't around
reporting and where the reporting takes
place and what kinds of experiences
we've had in Canada and around of
reporting now it's interesting that you
mentioned that because there's been a
bit of a it's been a lot of changes in
the last I would say two to three years
in Canada in around technology and do
stairs first of all we had a
sensitization in the vendor environment
as well as the clinical environment
these these particular types of errors
occur so now you have these errors in
where do you actually report and there
are no unique reporting systems for
technology induced errors okay so there
was a period where people were reporting
them to their incident to the incident
reporting systems at the local regional
health authority there were people who
were also reporting it at a national
level and when it involved medications
what happened well and also at to health
canada which is similar to your FDA so
Health Canada what was interesting is
they looked at electronic health records
and medical records and they identified
that in certain cases they are like
medical devices so they are labeled as
medical devices and with that you have
reporting that takes place now with
reporting it's kind of an interesting
area one of the things that that I have
known it is as you know we all know what
unintended consequences we know what
technology knust error is in fact it's
really interesting because we know that
language our language needs to be
transferred to the health professionals
like I can tell you that I've presented
this lecture and other lectures to
health professionals where you know they
don't know what it is but then
when you give him a definition and some
examples is like I I've had these things
happen I didn't realize I was supposed
to be reporting them I thought I was
just supposed to call it in to the help
desk you know and and yet you know it's
it's you know it so once we sensitize
individuals I actually fully expect
there's going to be a spike in terms of
the types of reports that are out there
just because people are now aware what
that means and how it affects their work
the good thing about that is that we're
going to bring from that iceberg we're
going to bring a little bit more up
we're going to see more and they were in
able to be able to address more of these
types of errors from a from a health
informatics community perspective
through the through the software
development lifecycle and through to
maintenance of the systems over the long
term and the other piece of it is we're
going to influence next generation
products with these best practices that
some of them which you've identified
here and published about it's so we'll
have better systems over time yes
so if I can if I can recap this so
you're looking at your you want to know
how we can go about addressing errors
that arrays arise from the system design
and errors that arise from an
implementation perspective and how we
can actually influence this process but
I think this idea of having a model
where you're actually doing testing
along the way is really important okay
certainly we have to ask the vendors to
do the testing okay with prototypes and
we need to identify any potential issues
within those prototypes and as they
build the system and it becomes
something that can be sold in the
marketplace then what happens is we have
people who purchase systems okay in
Denmark one of the things they're doing
is they're actually doing this type of
testing before they actually purchase a
system there identify the best system
for their regional health authority the
best features and functions that it has
now if you make customizations to this
system another educational point is that
health information technology
professionals need to understand that
when you do that you can introduce new
types of errors so they need to be
cognizant of what the implications of
that is so they need to also do some
testing locally and like I said we've
had signals with people who have
graduated from our program who actually
do local testing so you can do local
testing in Euro r during off-hours you
can do local testing in our room that
isn't being used for patient care as in
the japanese example so you can start to
see what the implications of your
changes to or your customizations of
that system are at that level and so
again you know this is all about
creating a safer system overtone
you know and it's it's it's all about
organizational learning to at different
levels so vendor and also from from an
organization the healthcare
organizational perspective it comes down
altima tlie to to organizational
behavior flowing through this and making
people think that we have to actually
look at this from a systems perspective
I hope I answered your question yes yes
well that's a good question i mean i I
don't know I you know it would be great
to be able to design a study to see if
it had an effect right and if it does
have a positive effect right then I
think that's that's great and that needs
to be published because maybe what we
what we need to do is have more of a
role of governments in terms of
regulating this okay I can tell you in
Canada there are promises that have
identified specific vendors that were
that were that were in essence they
recommended for use and part of that was
doing usability testing ok now what
effect it had in terms of reducing error
rates I'm not sure that's the kind of
study that you can do and find out right
so it's important yes
uh no I wouldn't say that I can't say
from a researchers perspective but as a
person who had worked in clinical
informatics we do do testing at the
organizational level even for
customizations so this is sort of
sifting the focus on that on the testing
to actually start looking at it in terms
of potential opportunities to induce
introduce errors so it's not a bad thing
I mean it's a more testing we do the
lime you know it's like pruning a tree
off your pruning off the errors right so
you have fewer errors over time and then
that clinician doesn't get in a
situation where something bad happens
yes the person in orange shirt I
apologize
but the whole paradigm by which these
systems are designed and really we need
to think of a different way to design
electronic record systems that don't
have you know a million different panels
and dialog boxes and dense tables and
you know that whole sort of you know for
lack of a better way to said just
transfer to paper chart for the screen
do you have a feeling out the balance of
that you know safety is sort of you know
so i guess so the question is is do we
do we take this incremental approach in
terms of pruning off errors or do we
actually create some new type of design
that's more safer that's a very very
good question it I think we're kind of
in some ways having to do some of that
incremental work right now because we
have so many health information systems
implemented so that has to be done
because people are just going to hold
those things I would overnight that said
I think there's value to looking at
differing types of designs that would be
safer so some of the work that's being
done here is really important from the
perspective that you're looking at
something that would be safer so it
might be disruptive in essence to the
existing market and perhaps because it's
safer more people will buy it over time
I think we will have something that's
safer it's going to take a long time why
you know you look at some of the the
literature in the aviation industry I
mean airplanes aircraft been around
since the nineteen orly 1900s right
we're really it's a safe industry it
wasn't for a while there okay a long
time it wasn't safe but what they did is
they took the information and they
brought it back in as a feedback
mechanism and use that as guides and
ways of actually enhancing future
aircraft so today we have something
that's very very safe that's flying out
there and I
I mean it's wonderful because you've got
Boeing here but but the the other part
of it too is is that you know if we if
we don't start investing now and don't
recognize this is an ongoing process we
won't get to that level where it's the
safest industry out there and I think we
can get to that level yes
there's no
no and it is it is partially a culture
shift also I mean you know you have
pilots that are aware of potential
issues with aircraft they're given
information in real time they train on a
particular type of aircraft they know
how it feels how it works in situations
that are routine and non-routine okay so
you know over time the people actually
the the pilots contributed to the to the
advancement of that knowledge there was
research that went into it engineers
everyone along that path okay and
they're certainly socialized to say hey
there's a problem okay so what we need
to do I think as a healthcare industry
say hey there's a problem and then have
half that addressed and disseminate that
knowledge not keep it behind some back
door and say we fixed our problem we're
not going to tell anybody else about it
we need to say we fix this perm this is
the way we did it and we want people to
know how that's done so that you don't
have that issue occur for you ever I
mean it go back and then over yes
two systems perspective the punitive
aspects of areas within the environment
today years ago the difference is that I
shoot the way the traditions they about
how we approach errors so that should be
fine answers once for some TV
we honestly shocked by the commenters is
that you know the culture among
clinicians is changing in that we're now
looking at things in terms of not
blaming individuals but looking at
things from a systems approach you know
it's really important I mean I what I
see because I teach people about health
technology and they're they're
individuals who deal with that that back
end is that we need to recognize there
are different partners in this process
and we need to bring these different
individuals together so we can actually
improve those systems and it even goes
as far as to sensitize governments about
this too because you know today you
change legislation the workflow is
different for what the legislation says
that person's supposed to do and you're
putting that person that's actually
using the system in a situation where
they might make an error now because the
workflow is different so you know again
it's multiple different players looking
at it from a systems approach and under
an understanding how that works in order
to prevent any errors from occurring now
I saw another hand out there yes yes
no I I haven't looked at that per se but
there is some research literature was
really kind of interesting depending on
I've run across an article to wear
depending on the degree to which an
organization relies on technology to
support health care processes you can
have significant rise in the number of
error rates now that could be because
you're relying on the technology more so
now that said if you recognize that and
that's a potential issue that you need
to actually go and start developing
organizational policies procedures and
even looking at it from a process
perspective to prevent that from
occurring especially if you are having
data transmitted from one organization
to another one yes yes yes yes really
important and I mean that's again that's
may not be something that a clinician
necessarily can fix right but they can
identify and when it occurs that's not
something that needs to be brought up at
with the vendors that are involved as
well as institutions that are involved
because you know you're going
cross-institutional at that point that's
a very good point yes
I assume you can sit round people have
more questions but thank you very much
there's lovely being me